john time good luck john ooh i know what
to play against john
this is part part three
of knight's c3
i know what i want to do this game too
but do i reveal it oh i remember i told
john to play this move last time
so now i have a choice i can play e4 or
d4 or knight f3
i'll play knight f3 i'll make things
spicy the two nights attack
was it youtube
we'll see if it goes on youtube then
probably
a spicy opening
i could trade queens i also could take
let's take with f pawn this open f file
is um
actually looks kind of nice bishop f5
okay this is three old blitz
good thing to realize before i get so
low on time
thanks for subbing oh thanks for gifting
a sub white noise
gifting a sub to nasir shout out to
nayseer
if nasir is in the chat oh nasir is in
the chat
um play d6
oh thanks white noise i'm doing work so
i don't have to
yeah nasir also has a twitch channel
people should
should check around good content
what is this position this is like a
like we're both following opening
principles except this knight
hmm
i'll play e4 just to make this bishop
sad
and e4 makes this bishop happy
each one i'm scared though i'm scared of
john's
john's piece coordination i have is a
threat
probably queen e2
my plan is c3 and d4
and john is playing very much in the
style
h4 is coming play bishop g5
so if f6 i'll i'll plant the bishop here
blockade the pawn
john's probably considering h4 sacko
queen and then try and mate me
no way that works so probably just h3 in
that line
it's still sharp okay i'll play c3
preparing the the central expansion
i was more expecting e5 f5
free pawn
this is like um he takes that five it is
a free pawn but it's a fork
it's also a pin the combination of a
fork and a pin
is a pork all i wanna do
noobs i see what you mean
all i want to do is pork stuff
the combination of pin and fork
it's a nice nice thing in chess at
bishop f7 i
again this would just be a continuation
fork
f5 backfired if the king was already
safe f5 probably would have been a good
move
but my bishop my bishop prevents the
king from castling
at least queenside interesting knight e3
so i'll take i'll take on e6
and now basically i'm attacking the
queen i'm also probably
creating a situation where the knight
will be pinned
hmm i'll play d4
i really don't care about this rook i
just care about attacking more things
and john john running low on time
the pork is too real it's really no
longer a pork
unless it is a pork i mean it's still a
double attack and a pin
it's a nice kind of retreating move okay
let's win material
and the king's tied down to the knight
and my five hmm
is bishop f7
i mean there's so many good looking
moves here no time to think okay let's
just win the night
there's no way for black to defend the
night a third time
oh it's a triple fork it's a
what's a wooden shield no it's a trident
the trident is uh
times three
[Music]
ah i'm sure the youtube people can maybe
relate
okay we're going to go and try and make
somehow
where's my mate oh the flag is
is almost as good also triple pawns
i could have won connect four missed my
opportunity
anyway thanks for the game john another
unfortunate game
another time being a victim of uh of
knight c3
actually i i don't know like if i were
black i don't know what i would play
against d5
or against knight f3 if i would play d4
i think d4 makes sense i don't think
i've ever studied this specific position
maybe f5 could be neat
theory wow white has a 100
win win rate in the masters database
only out of three games but that's still
impressive
uh most strong players play knight f6
makes sense
maybe a safer move
yeah john john was probably doing well
until f5
f5 apart from just losing all the
material
it also prevented black from castling so
um i was really expecting e5 here
and then it's harder to play d4
[Music]
i still like the position but
oh there's also 93 to consider
stockfish and knight e3
e5 maybe not as strong oh because b4
anyway um john john has been a victim of
these youtube videos
but i think that's going on youtube
so youtube people thanks for watching
and
don't forget to like and subscribe